[Music]
physician heal thyself
[Applause]
[Music]
night of the doctor god I love the short
so much this is is is seriously one of
my favorite pieces of Doctor Who it's
not even seven minutes long but it's
Paul McGann just owning this part so
well I mean it's it's great that he's
had Big Finish for a long time since he
originally played the part in the
made-for-tv movie to really perfect how
he does this but to get to see him play
it is just wonderful and I love the
misdirect right at the start of this
thing where you know first of all let's
be honest cuz people are gonna point out
in the comments this video is longer
than the thing you're reviewing yes it
will be I'm gonna gush so you've got him
yo I'm a doctor but probably not the one
you're expecting like what a great
misdirect his name right there right at
the top of the credits oh it's so good
and I love his his attitude he doesn't
miss a beat it's all just so great him
meeting somebody for the first time you
know where's the rest of the crew i
teleported them off Oh welcome aboard
where are we going back to the ship why
cuz the front crashes first think it
through he's so quick and he's just
rapid-fire all this stuff I really like
that about McGann's doctor he is very
quick with his responses to most things
and I also really like that he stays
true to his word because when Kass
realizes he's a Time Lord and she
refuses to go with him because she's
someone who knows about the time war and
she considers the Time Lords to be just
as bad as the Daleks
she refuses to go with him he says he's
not leaving this ship without her and
that's true he stays on as it crashes
and he dies he didn't have to do that
but that's who the eighth doctor was he
was gonna keep trying to talk her into
coming onto the TARDIS right up at the
point that it killed him oh I love that
I absolutely love that and then you've
got the sisters of Cora and you've got
the the weight that comes with that
because they know what needs to happen
and the doctor knows but he doesn't want
it he doesn't want to admit to it he
doesn't want to take this step he has
been fighting for so long to not have to
do this plus it's got one of my one of
my all-time favorite lines new doctor
four minutes
well that's ages well if I get bored I
need a television a couple of books and
they want four chests bring me knitting
uh right up to the well past the end
he's already died at that point and he
still he's still cracking wise Paul
McGann is so good in this part I mean
there was a reason that even before the
casting of Jodie Whittaker cause half
the Phantom's lose its damn mind well
before that even happened there were
people going hey hey any chance we could
get a spinoff would the eighth doctor
and he's just for just like a single
series something we want to see more of
him in this part and I'm I'm not gonna
say that I wish the BBC had done that
because I I think you create a situation
doing that where the word doctor who is
effectively competing with itself and I
don't think that's healthy for the
franchise but I get why there are people
who then and now say this is what we
want I get it
cuz he's so so good and it's and for
people who don't
listen to Big Finish there's a good
chance that this is going to be their
only experience of the eighth doctor and
if this is gonna be it for you this is
still a really solid representation of
who he is what he's about why he is
great and I just so many little details
like right down to the end where he's
got this thing it's gonna trigger his
regeneration and make him the warrior
that he's afraid to be and he hasn't won
he's been fighting hard to not be any
ass will it hurt
and the woman tells him s this is good
because he doesn't want this to be easy
he wants this to hurt he wants this to
go badly he wants to be punished
preemptively for what he's going to do
so many great things about this that
said I did pay particular attention
watching it this time and I thought
before rewatching it for God I don't
know like the 20th time that I was gonna
come in here and go again I have no
criticisms whatsoever to make and that's
not true I've actually got one it's the
camerawork particularly in the
back-and-forth between him and the
sisters of carne because holy crap is it
shaky like it's really bad and part of
why it's so notice the cameras shaky at
the front end on the ship but that ships
crashing it's fine that the camera won't
stay still but these are shot reverse
shot dialogue scenes nobody's moving the
ground isn't shaking there's no reason
for the camera to be moving as much as
it is and it's a lot it's it's a
distracting amount now Magan is so
magnetic that you can still easily zero
in on him and hold him
even as the frame keeps doing this but
it's just it's a scene that there's no
reason for the camera to move be moving
around like that and what doesn't help
is whenever they go to something that
isn't the close-ups or the mediums for
the shot reverse shot of the dialogue
and they like cut back as you know to a
different angle when he gets up when he
goes to see casas body and things like
that it's a completely locked off shot
absolutely like it's it's on a tripod or
it's on over it's something no movement
then it goes back to the close-up mm-hmm
stop stop it ah that's really irritating
that said I'm making a slightly bigger
deal out of it then might be actually
warranted because it's pretty much the
only complaint I have to register you
know and and also the fun thing to
remember is that at the time this aired
it was the confirmation of where the war
doctor fell in the doctors continuity
because the thing was when the name of
the doctor aired we had that reveal John
Hurt as the doctor we didn't know what
that meant
where'd this fit into things I limited
how much speculation that I looked at at
the time I'd seemed like most people
were thinking that it was an early
incarnation of the doctor possibly from
before he took the name of the doctor
and that was why the doctor the Matt
Smith's doctor was like no he's not the
doctor so I know that was a common
theory my theory at the time was that he
was actually a future incarnation of the
doctor and I hinged that almost entirely
on the line from Matt Smith in name of
the doctor you know the name you choose
is like a promise you make he's the one
who broke the promise I'm like well he
can't be from before the doctor who took
on the name of the doctor because
break a promise you haven't made yet and
if the name is the promise and he broke
it that means it has to have been later
so my assumption was that he was a
future incarnation who for whatever
reason possibly time or related the
doctor knew a future version of him was
going to do something horrible that was
my subject and I was wrong and this and
this proved it but it is kind of cool
that this short actually has
significance to the overall plot of
what's going on in these last episodes
of Matt Smith's run because this placed
the war doctor and we got the the you
know it's it's a little bit faded it's
like in a reflection but we got young
John Hurt which was cool and this thing
is just so like this the script as far
as I'm concerned is absolutely brilliant
and the performance is one it is spot-on
like the other actors are fine but like
business McGann show and the performance
is 100% exactly what it should be he
knows this part so well the only thing
that drags it down is the camera work
but it's so short like that shouldn't
put you off from watching it or
rewatching it or RiRi watching it what
was the last time you watched it watch
it again it's so good night of the
doctor what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it and you know all the stuff
to do like share subscribe patreon etc
etc etc well you don't have to do any of
it because at the end of the day you're
the council
I'm just running the meets and until
next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]